candid
truth hello everybody and welcome back
to candid truth we
are back once again we're going to
tackle a topic that is something we're
we're in the middle of right now and the
question is what does Gwen Stefani Mark
Wahlberg Jonathan
roomy and Chris Pratt and even several
others have to do
with well what do they have in common
basically and that's the question well
they all are trying to put out
advertisements for an app called hallo
if you haven't heard of this they are
actually inviting you to take part in
Lent days of prayer for Lent during Lent
on this app called hallo we can see
that they've all been featured on the
Hallow advertisements there's Mark
Wahlberg Chris Pratt go Stefani all
asking you to come join in using this
prayer app we also have um Lauren dagel
of course we all pretty much in the
Christian World know her because she's a
Christian artist but there's a
recent development there as well which
we'll get into with her
and then there's also Mike Schmidt
forgive me I don't know his name
completely but he's also endorsed it but
they've all been featured to endorse
this app first of all I didn't know that
lent was a Christian thing where did
that come from you
know
so man we're going to dive into this and
get a little deeper hey guys Mark
Wahlberg here you've heard me say it
before but I'm going to say it again you
guys have to check out hallow this Lent
we are doing something really powerful
it's a 40-day prayer challenge for every
day of Lent with Jonathan roomy far Mike
Schmitz and of course yours truly we are
going through the incredible book The
Way by St Jose Maria SCA and I along
with my buddy Chris Pratt will lead us
through weekly fasting challenges join
me and millions of others around the
world praying every day this Lent stay
prayed up and God bless you
okay so there is that and then on their
website for the hall app you have this
this perfect little popup that comes up
um join Mark Wahlberg and Jonathan roomy
and pray every day on hallow this
Lent okay so if we go
back to
our our slides
here we are going to take a look because
God tells us for one
that we are to look at people's fruits
when I ask the question you know I guess
the question is where did Lent pop up
when where did it come
from but is it even
Christian and when you look at these
people's lives you're supposed to look
at their fruits and if they bear fruit
of
Christianity and unfortunately we're not
really seeing that we look at Mark
Wahlberg's movies and one good example
is Ted unrated it had as you can see
from uh the ratings it had a lot of
language I heard that it had almost 300
F bombs dropped in it um has tons of
drinking and drugs and smoking sex
romance
nudity um violence and scariness for a
little teddy
bear guy that's joining Mark Wahlberg in
his life doing all this with him so it's
really messed up
and then we have Chris Pratt um he's
played in many movies Guardians of the
Galaxy where they're literally fighting
against the Creator coming in the you
know the recent ones is that they're all
supposed to gather together to fight
against the Creator and ruler coming
down in the
skies and um then in this one we're
talking about the
passenger uh he had a sex scene with
Jennifer
Lawrence and although she apparently
admitted that she had to use a lot of
anxiety and booze to get her through it
he said that it was his duty to make her
feel
comfortable um during the entire thing
so he's not
exactly for I mean he's not saying he's
not for the sex scene he was totally
fine with it it
seems and um Lauren dagel I mentioned
something came up with well she is now
saying that she doesn't really want to
be considered a Christian artist but
simply an artist and she's also taken
some very interesting stances when it
comes to
homosexuality she's pretty much become a
supporter and um she seems to be also
saying
that the different steps or different
ways to God are all different for people
um um even that God changes he becomes
different things to different people and
so that's a scary statement and um not
sure it's really a great situation for
her they're
all they're giving up certain things to
be in this Limelight and we're going to
take a look a little bit at that as
well so this hallow app um it was feed
featured on news Nation with Jonathan
room is the creator by the way um so
he's talking about it and it has become
the biggest Prayer app in the entire
world he admits it there um this is a
big deal we haven't heard about it that
much there's been some advertisements
I've seen it myself um on like YouTube
and so on
but all of a sudden it's blown up like
all of these celebrities all the actors
everyone that's just joining him from
around the world to do this and of
course his role in The Chosen was very
pivotal for this um release of the app
him playing Jesus and um he's you know
if you really want to know and you've
understood where he comes from he is a
knight's
Templar uh member and so he's got a
lot um a lot of weight in the world but
it's not exactly for the
good and um
so it was the biggest Prayer app come
that's come out has gained huge
popularity
everywhere um we are going to be talking
about
um we'll just pause there for a minute
we're going to be talking more
about what has happened with the
morphing of Lent into our society
today well
before we go thinking that we might want
to join hallow or um keep lent
ourselves we need to question what it is
I guess and it was particularly a time
for fasting before Easter it was
supposed to be when um you gave up
certain lavish foods and and behaviors
and activities as most people will tell
you when they're keeping it um you can
fast from TV you can fast from food you
can fast from social media many
different things
but did we happen to know that these
things of course as you might have
guessed came from Pagan
Roots they
are well in historically speaking it's
also called shr Tuesday or Mar
gr or Fat
Tuesday and the term Fat Tuesday in
French comes to us but in England it's
called pancake Tuesday so we've had it
handed down to us in many different ways
today we kind of just celebrate them all
and what is the
purpose the purpose of this day was
actually made to indulge in excess
especially rich foods before entering
the fasting season of
Lent this is where I wanted to show you
guys that
our
[Music]
um this overindulgence comes from
honoring the Roman Festival go fertility
God sorry luer Calia with feasting
drinking and carnal
behaviors this is still what we have
going on usually when we
have you know Burning Man Marty gr all
this stuff and that's because the
celebrations today have an ancient
origin far removed from Christian
Traditions as it says right there that's
from the smithonian institution for
talking about Ash
Wednesday well historically for us it
was
yesterday and we saw people marking
their heads and they will tell you it's
a symbol of repent like repentance
and
um giving up something for Christ and
keeping your eyes on the
cross as we approach the resurrection of
our Lord and so on but unfortunately the
mark place on the forehead has
everything to do with
Mystic um ancient origins of the cross
it actually is the mark of Mystic
Tow and it was the initial because it's
a t of the God tamuz as written in
Egyptian hieroglyphics you can see it
see it elsewhere also but this Mark was
once used in the initiation rights so
take this and put it in mind it was used
as an initiation ritual into the
mysteries of Tao honoring Gods like
Aphrodite and other gods as part of the
ancient Pagan practice
and that's from encyclopedia
britanica all right so as we get further
into this we will see it has many other
meanings um
lent this is what I'm reading not from
this slide here but I'll go ahead and
read this um as well it says lent which
supposedly mirrors the 40 days that
Jesus spent fting in the wilderness
actually comes from the Anglo-Saxon word
lenon meaning spring and that
is that is on the slide up
there um it's spelled l n c TN meaning
spring it actually originated in the
ancient Babylonian mystery
religions the 40 days abstinence of Lent
was directly borrowed from the worship
ERS of Babylonian goddess among the
pagans this Lent seems to have been an
indispensable preliminary to the Greek
great Annual Festival in commemoration
of the death and resurrection of
tamuz that is from the Two
Babylons a book by Alexander Hislop I
believe
now the
origins really do
come from the worship of the Sun God
where 40 days of weeping were held for
tamuz a pagan God who died at the age of
40 now here's the thing to keep in mind
it was said that he died at the age of
40 after being killed by a wild
boar now why do we as a society we're
told to eat a
ham on Easter Sunday when the time of
Lent is over
just ask yourself
that well the days of Lent are used to
mourn tamu's death marking each year of
his Incarnation they say why because the
connection to tamuz doesn't end there he
was a counterfeit Messiah as you can see
here on the slides the second uh
paragraph he was the false Messiah of
the Babylonians a satanic counterfeit of
Jesus
Christ the Feast of tamuz was usually
celebrated in June lent was held 40 days
before the Feast celebrated by alternate
weeping and
rejoicing this is why lent means spring
it took place from Spring to early
summer the Bible records ancient Judah
worshiping this false
Messiah and it says then he brought me
to the door of the Gate of the Lord's
House which was towards the North and
behold there sat women weeping for tamuz
in Ezekiel 81
14-15 this was a great abomination in
the eyes of God and indeed it was we can
see that it's mentioned a few other
times as well in the Bible and God
never endorses it he wants us to stay
away from the worship of other
gods
so to add to this it says
um after the 40 days let's look let's
look first of all at what happened
during the time in Rome before everyone
supposedly converted to
Christianity it says to conciliate the
pagans to nominal Christianity Rome
pursuing its usual policy took measures
to get the Christian and Pagan festivals
Amalgamated that means to come together
and over overlap to become one and by a
complicate a complicated but skillful
adjustment of the
calendar it was found no difficult
matter in general to get paganism and
Christianity now far sunk into
idolatry in this as in
so
well this is indeed true and we have
seen that over and over again if you're
new here um you can go check out my
other
um presentations on this but many times
over the Catholic Church does in fact
repurpose many holidays that are pagan
in every land and every culture and
bring them in among their fold to be
proclaimed as Christian and kept and
declared that they should be kept very
sternly upon usually
um punishment of death until it's
brought into the entire culture so we've
already been through that and it's
become a huge deal to us and um that's
where it came
from okay something of note is that
prior to the birth and death of Jesus
before Abraham was even born lent was a
period of penance and abstinence for 40
days to mourn it already existed before
any any of
them as a 40-day Time days to mourn the
death of
tamuz now we already said this I already
talked about it because of him being
supposedly killed by a pig at the age of
40 and you lament
each uh year of his life for a day and
at the end of that morning on the Sunday
after the Spring Equinox tamuz would
supposedly come back to life be
resurrected or reincarnated in the
agricultural world would flourish and
animals would become fertile the 40-day
morning and Penance had to end on the
Sunday after the first full moon after
March 21st to coincide with the worship
of Easter the goddess of fertility now
if you really put that together that's a
big deal and I will show that later
but why was it dictated that it always
had to be a Sunday for one and then
we'll ask the second question later like
it's incredible that really in some ways
it doesn't make
sense so we can see right here um
there's an
interesting fact that as The Story Goes
it states at the very top the myth
further stated that the child was called
tamuz Son Of The Sun God he was
responsible for Bright Light sorry
bringing light into the world and to
fight Darkness can you guess when tamuz
was
born good question in their article they
say if you said at the winter solstice
which is December 22nd through 25th you
are correct for those steeped in
religious studies you will recall the
Invictus Soul the unconquerable son that
was a God that was born on the shortest
day of the year of the saturnalia or the
saturnalia December 22nd through 25th
and we worship Him Today every December
25th that is actually TAMU
some customs called him Baal or Mithra
and more recently Jesus Christ since the
Council of NAA in ad 320 to legitimize
its
worship again an apple By Any Other Name
is still an
apple continuing on to the second
paragraph the myth climaxed with the
idea that tamuz at age 40 went hunting
and was killed by a boar all right same
thing in order to bring back her
son tamuz to life an elaborate scheme
was devised so this is tamu's Mother
Samus the idea required 40 days of
mourning for tamuz a day for each year
of his life at the end of 40 days of
morning tamuz returns to Life on Sunday
after the first full
moon after March
21st abstinence from
meat self and lust was the order of the
day for the 40 days of Lent
okay we have to come to the end of this
and what they have to say to wrap this
up is the myth climaxed with the idea
that tamuz at age 40 went hunting we
already read that part I'm sorry
so
at oh here we are at the end of Lent a
boar is killed and ham is eaten Sweet
Revenge on the pig that killed tamuz yes
it is kind of like that but Marty grow
here we go or Fat Tuesday was a day
before lent where people can Revel in
carnal Affairs meaning carnivals if we
we've all heard that word and have sex
and promis promiscuous Behavior prior to
the 40 days of
penitence as a myth would have it tamu's
mother Samus died and the gods looked
favorably on her as she was the mother
of the son of the son God she was sent
back to Earth as the spring fertility
goddess asth or
Easter always shown as a well-endowed
bare breasted queen of fertility
according to the myth she emerged from a
giant egg that landed in the Euphrates
river at sunrise on the
Sunday after the full moon after the
Spring
Equinox
okay so
much discourse so much um
I don't know preparation for this all to
come about right and this is the point
that I was making earlier the date of
Easter is determined by calculating the
first Sunday after the full moon that
occurs on or after the vernal equinox
that is true every
time however it's a Movable Feast so it
doesn't happen on the same date from
year to
year now here's where the question is if
if it Christ's birthday let's put it in
terms of that if it truly were Christ uh
s sorry not birthday but his
resurrection date and it really mattered
to us wouldn't it just be
solid someone's birthday or someone's
event happens on one day and you want to
commemorate it it's that day and the day
doesn't change and the date Remains the
Same why would this follow lunar and
solar patterns of the sky
if indeed it was not a solar or lunar
deity that it was
worshiping Pagan
worship I don't see how it could be
anything else to be honest we just saw
how you cannot
repurpose what you know what it's been
in history it cannot be repurposed to be
kept towards God the true God or Jesus
Christ but let's let's fur further that
let's take a deeper look so here's
something that came up and before we
read this there is a connection here a a
large
connection there is Good Friday and Palm
Sunday now Good Friday is the tradition
of a fish fry which honors the fish God
day gone another ancient deity and then
Palm Sunday which originated in Greek
and Roman culture representing Victory
peace and eternal life all connected to
worship of the palm tree in ancient
Egypt that came from Cambridge
University now this particular article
that I'm showing you is directly about
palm trees and general and how they were
the symbol of paradise and
relaxation and they were used to
evoke many different things within
spiritual worship if you'll jump down to
the last sentence of the first paragraph
it says from the ancient Egyptians to
the Greeks and Romans palm trees has
palm trees have been revered and myth
mythologized for their beauty resilience
and
symbolism in ancient Egypt the palm tree
was a symbol of resurrection and eternal
life Resurrection does anyone does that
ring a bell for anybody this coming
Easter the ancient Egyptians believed
that the palm tree represent presented
the god of
creation atum or
Adam who is said to have created himself
out of a palm
tree because the tree's ability to
regenerate and thrive in harsh desert
conditions made it a powerful symbol of
rebirth and
renewal they are often planted in Temple
Gardens and used in religious rituals
with their fronds symbolizing Victory
and Triumph over death
so we also see it in the last paragraph
here in Greek and Roman mythology the
palm tree was associated with various
gods and goddesses including Apollo
Hercules and Venus is often depicted in
art and literature as a symbol of
Victory peace and
fertility and the Greeks believed that
the palm tree was a gift from the god
Apollo who planted the first palm tree
at delos the sacred island of his
birth Okay so palm tree worship is a
part of this as
well
and I think that's well linked well
shown but it also
states that we have festivities as I
mentioned
carnivals um all kinds of other things
going
on and I do in fact know that today even
in parts of the United Kingdom they
actually have what it's called and still
celebrate Pancake Day with races pancake
races um as they used to even be
called
and having leftovers from it is a
leftover I should say from Pagan
rituals but it comes also from the
worship of the Goddess Vesta or
Hestia um goddess of the Hearth and
Home Carnival around the world from
Venice to to Rio De Janeiro and even
Germany still hold practices with
vibrant costumes and music we can see
that all around us if we just look it up
these celebrations often culminate in
the burning of a straw or wicker man
Effigy a practice linked to Saturn
worship that is true that is from
National Geographic actually when they
went to Burning Man and so this is what
it truly is from ancient Antiquity times
to
now so as we progress
further let me just make sure we've got
this um oh it was on there we're going
to jump down to the last paragraph here
in England the Royal shr football
games yes that's right they did have
football games attached to this as well
it was once played on shro Tuesday and
Ash Wednesday this annual game involved
two teams from opposite sides of a town
symbolizing rivalry and Community
cohesion with hundreds of people
competing it's an ancient form of
competition that has evolved into our
modern-day Super
Bowl did anyone ever realize this or
think that it was connected with an
ancient
practice good old Super Bowl
all right
so it so it was it's turned into our
modernday Super Bowl where the entire
nation gathers to watch an intense
symbolic
battle
now let me explain a little bit about
these games you would separate into two
teams and each team would be if you were
from a certain Town closest to the river
basically
any one that lived closest to the river
would be in the first team and the
second would be
a a town or vicinity from which you were
farther away and you'd be called the
upwards if you were closer to the river
and
downwards now you had to rely on each
other to get the ball from your
teammates of course and play this
football game it was men women children
and basically it was survival the
fittest it was almost a um
experiment that was supposed to be fun
during that time to see who would
survive and who wouldn't in coming times
of
trouble such as drought or
famine and um one opposing Town pretty
much because it would be you on a a team
with the entire town pretty much that
you had lived your whole life in against
another you would join in having pretty
much
a
ritualized
competition just like the old times just
like an
Antiquity and so that's where we also
have football games
attached so in a lot of this we will
begin to understand that even with these
celebrities joining in being a part of
it I didn't even know like lent is a
Catholic thing so I didn't know that
these people were catholic let alone
Christian and now all of a sudden it's a
fully what's sounding like a fully
Christian thing to keep lent and use
this app called
hallow
and let's just remember that as they're
doing this I think it serves a purpose
it serves the purpose of getting us all
to the point of
wanting they're hoping that it will sway
you with people who are High esteem and
fame in the world to want to do it as
well to join
in but as it's rooted in Pagan practices
as we can
see let's just take that into
consideration let's have more
discernment why because the Bible tells
us clearly not to worship as the
heathens do as seen in
Deuteronomy
12 oops
12: 30 and
31 which says take heed to thyself that
thou be not ens snared by following them
after that they be destroyed from before
thee and that thou inquire not after
their gods saying how did these nations
serve their gods even so will I do
likewise Thou shalt not do so unto the
Lord your God for every Abomination to
the Lord which he hateth have they done
unto their gods for even their sons and
their daughters they have burnt in the
fire to their
gods so as we enter into this season and
it's going on around us let's remember
to stay true to the word of God and
understand the truth about these
things not to be swayed At All by the
traditions of
man thank you for watching I'm really
glad you guys were here thanks for
tuning in
and please support us like subscribe and
share but thank you guys so much for
coming and listening we appreciate all
of you guys love you and we will talk to
you guys later